this is a faculty level initiative where
people see an opportunity to do
something that they could have not
otherwise done so it's not that somebody
was told hey you're going to collaborate
with UCL you're going to do this and
that works in the military but not in
but not in academia it's really because
people see this as a very exciting
opportunity if the primary goal is to
try and reach a level of creativity in
quality of idea that we wouldn't have
achieved by ourselves as the prime the
primary goal and then the secondary goal
is to share our equipment and our
experience certainly we can have economy
of what we're doing then the third goal
is to use things on the other side that
we don't have the vlu seal collaborative
came about as a cardiovascular ism as a
kind of a secular program and at the
beginning we did not have an ambition
for anything bigger than that we thought
that the thought that the transatlantic
area vascular program was ambitious
enough but it but as others have heard
about it it became it became very clear
that there is a much broader interest I
would say probably there are a hundred
people involved but outside that there
are there are lots of people influenced
by it that is environments are now
projects joint projects being undertaken
in the humanities particularly in
history
where there was a retreat last year in
UCL in philosophy where ever discussing
Plato's concept of the mind architecture
and forestry are talking to each other
about the environment and engineering
want a different sort of relationship I
think whereby their students will have
internships in the other university it
spread to school so forestry law law
graduate school
history Judaic Studies our goal is to
get to a point where the Sun doesn't
doesn't doesn't set on the earliest year
there are remarkable signatures and our
senior scientists lecture series which
is now moving to its second year has
been really a very successful enterprise
here really really we're beginning to
sort of introduce of the scientific
communities to each other it's very much
a grassroots movement it's where people
want to take it so if you put all that
together you can see there are a lot of
people involved and one of the things
we've got to do in the in the next stage
of the evolution of this is to
concentrate our activities on those
things that are going to be most
fruitful for both universities over the
next couple of years
you